[Music]
[Music]
hey here's the deal
100 grass-fed japanese kobe beef 35
a pound that's what i'm talking about
all right let's grill these little
homies up
right all right oh man is that ground
chuck man i know i'm fancy i ain't
trying to
park my bentley next to your toyota
oh you're just putting them right next
to the frozen pack yeah
all right hey relax man i'm gonna cook
em good okay
all right so uh how's theresa doing
she's good she's good she's sad she
couldn't be here you know she's got a
closing today you wanna flash cook those
because they're real lean you know
they're grass-fed so you just want to
probably flip them
right right now hey who wants cheese on
that burger nobody
nobody nobody wants cheese anybody want
a double burger no nobody wants a double
burger we're not gonna double that's
like putting
a diamond ring on a pa golf i'm sorry
but the grass
that these cows ate cost more than this
house all right no double burgers
hey what the hell you may as well just
poop on that
what you just ketchup raped my kobe
burger
this was a mistake this no
no no oh no no no no no no see this meat
came all the way over here from the
pacific ocean
by boat because the air pressure
wouldn't ruin any integrity give me that
you are not worthy you're not brother
all right
look ridiculous he's 126 oh this little
mother
126 was the beef
y'all not worthy did he take my dog
you